large numbers of the fighters go home
because they're from Europe their
passport holders born and raised and
many in most cases in Europe and as they
go into Europe into a back into a to a
continent that didn't know they'd left
for two or three or one years to fight
most of those countries as I mentioned
in my comments are Visa Waiver countries
we have to start looking very hard at at
that program not not eliminating it and
not doing anything excessive but look
very hard at that program and say what
do we need to do because you know the
real intent in many cases is for these
individuals to get to the United States
we are the Superbowl in terms of
terrorists and that's what they want to
do that's where they want to come
whether it's knocking down airplanes in
flight and you know I've taken some
decisions about that that we will likely
expand they want to get here they want
to do us harm and that's my concern now
that we're winning if you will in Iraq
and soon the win in in Syria that those
fighters go back to their homes in
Europe and then very possibly you make
the trip to the United States sobering
but I'm glad you're you're you're taking
that foresight to the next well because
the returning foreign fighter issue is a
vexing challenge including some of our
visa waiver programs I might also note
that other foreign terrorist
organizations potentially have been
biding their time al Qaeda has that
they're down but not out
and the reality is is is a direct
concern of the United States let me just
ask that the final question and I mean
you've served had a very distinguished
military career in all sorts of roles
and capacities everyone I've spoken to
will tell me this is a soldiers general
so that means a lot not a general
general you're a marine
yeah with all due respect to the
soldiers Murray sorry about that but the
reality is everyone will tell you that
you're you're thinking about the the men
and women on the very front lines on the
pointy end of the spear I mean now that
you're at the Department of Homeland
Security
they don't bode overly well in surveys
in terms of morale what what and and I'm
glad you mentioned the unity of effort
on steroids by the way which I think it
needs not a new Eagle steroid but but
where would you swear do you see things
going there and and and now that you
have an opportunity to speak to that and
I know you do every day that work for us
but what should we be thinking the rest
of us as citizens in terms of the men
and women well I mean you should think
about the fact that we haven't had an
airliner crash into a skyscraper in New
York and quite a while you should think
in terms that we haven't had a an
airliner that has been hijacked
you should think in terms of the number
of bad people that are illegal in our
country that are either not here anymore
or a hiding because Isis after them and
they're going to get them you can think
about the number of terrorists that
don't get through the CVP checkpoints
whether they're little and checkpoint C
or our air you know in in forty five and
a half years in the in the in the Marine
Corps it came to me that you can you can
get human beings to do anything you want
them to do they will invade and take Evo
Jima or they'll shine their shoes
you just have to teach them how to do it
you have to encourage them you have to
lead them and you have to give them
credit the worst I'm told morale and the
federal government is in this department
90 days ago I made a deal with the
people in this department that I would
protect them I got their back and I will
encourage them to do their jobs which
they're doing each and every day I
suspect not because of me but because of
the people they are that their morale is
already going in the right direction
again not because of Kelly but because
of what this administration has told
them to do within the law and they are
really really good people they are
remarkable in their dedication and every
American ought to be very very very
happy that they have men and women like
that fill out the ranks and DHS looking
out for them and their families
general Kelly mr. secretary thank you so
much for taking the time to join us
today thank you for your leadership and
please know you're calling on on all of
us in in whatever role we can play to
help so thank you mr. secretary
[Applause]
if you missed any of our coverage of
this discussion on homeland security
threats
go to our website c-span or check the
c-span video library and type homeland
security threats in the search box
[Music]
c---span where history unfolds daily in
1979 c-span was created as a public
service by America's cable television
companies and is brought to you today by
your cable or satellite provider all our
live coverage will continue this
afternoon with a discussion on the
results of turkeys referendum Turkish
voters recently approved constitutional
reforms that'll change the country's
system of government from a
parliamentary to a presidential one
we'll have live coverage from the
Washington Institute for Near East
policy at 12:30 p.m. Eastern here on
c-span and join us later today when
President Trump holds a rally in Kenosha
Wisconsin he's there to tour the snap-on
tool company and he'll sign an executive
order telling homeland security justice
labor and state departments to propose
new rules on visa fraud and the guest
worker visa program we'll have live
coverage of that starting at 3:20 p.m.
Eastern here on c-span also coming up
tonight dr. Ezekiel Emanuel the
University of Pennsylvania will talk
about efforts to build a more affordable
and effective healthcare system in this
country dr. Emanuel who served as an
Obama health care adviser is the author
of the book prescription for the future
he talks about health insurance costs
here in the US there's a portion of what
you'll see tonight you know we in this
room are very privileged in American
society very privileged I don't know
your incomes but I don't have to know
your incomes you're in health care
you're at the top of the healthcare heap
and you're wearing very nice clothes
okay we don't realize that the median in
America is 56,000 dollars for a
household not an individual okay now the
average employer sponsored insurance
premium when Pepperdine provides its
professors or its administrators
employer sponsored insurance across the
country 2016 the average premium all in
the employer contribution the employee
contribution and the kind
I'll tell you they're all the employee
contribution but none but we won't go
into that now
it's $18,000 right where the median
income in America is 56,000 one third of
the median income is health insurance
premiums I don't know is that
unaffordable to you seems outrageous to
me and you can see the entire interview
with dr. Emanuel at the University of
Pennsylvania tonight at 8:00 Eastern
here on c-span in case you missed it on
c-span CIA director Mike Pompeo on
national security and WikiLeaks because
while we do our best to quietly collect
information on those who pose a very
real threats to our country
individuals such as Julian Assange and
Edward Snowden seek to use that
information to make a name for
themselves as long as they make a splash
they care nothing about the lives they
put at risk or the damage they caused to
national security former Pakistani
President Pervez Musharraf I think those
who are blaming Pakistan are absolutely
wrong
they must understand Pakistan sacrifices
the role that we played and the
sacrifices we've given fighting
terrorism and we still continue to
sacrifice fighting terrorism NATO
secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg we
have been loyal to our core value our
core tasks ever since we were founded
back in 1949 and that is that we are an
alliance where we have promised to
protect each other one for all all for
one Nobel Prize laureate Malala
yousufzai addresses a joint session of
the Canadian Parliament around the world
130 million girls are out of school
today they may not have read the studies
and they may not know the statistics but
they understand that education is the
only path to a brighter future Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson on us-russia
relations we frankly discussed the
current state of yes Russia relations I
expressed the view that the current
state of us-russia relations is that
there is a low level of trust between
our two countries the world's two
foremost nuclear powers cannot have this
kind of relationship c-span programs are
available at c-span org on our home page
and by searching the video library
well this morning Washington journal
talked with former US ambassador to
Afghanistan Ryan Crocker about US
military action in Syria and Afghanistan
this is about 20 minutes joining us this
morning from Texas A&M University in
Texas former ambassador Ryan Crocker
who served as ambassador US ambassador
to six countries including Afghanistan
Syria and Iraq ambassador Crocker
welcome this morning we had you on the
asking you on this morning to talk about
our recent efforts in Syria and
Afghanistan in particular the military
efforts the tomahawk launched in Syria
and the Moab the bomb dropping in
Afghanistan the military side early on
in any way of the Trump foreign policy
what do you sense from which where you
sit and people you talk to that the
Trump administration is seeking to do on
the diplomatic side think of things in
regards to Syria and Afghanistan well
thanks for having me bill it has been a
fascinating hundred days we have not had
a president this internationally engaged
this early in the presidency since
George Herbert Walker Bush so for a an
individual who ran kind of on his
America first policies he has been a
very international president today
you've got the vice president in East
Asia you have the National Security
Advisor in South Asia and you have the
Secretary of Defense and in the Middle
East it doesn't get much more intense
than that the New York Times writing
about one of those foreign visitors
national security adviser HR McMaster
and their headline after us talks with
Afghanistan hints at a harder line on
Pakistan they write the talks between
the United States and Afghanistan
wrapped up here on Sunday as the Trump
administration reviews its options in
the 15 year
American presence in Afghanistan in the
face of a resurgent Taliban Lieutenant
General HR McMaster met with Afghan
leaders included including President
Ashraf Ghani in talks that came days
after the United States dropped a huge
bomb on a honeycomb of Islamic caves in
eastern Afghanistan but the greater
problem The New York Times writes in
Afghanistan is strength the
strengthening of the Taliban in an
interview with the Afghan television
channel Tolo news general McMaster said
what is necessary at this point is to
consolidate gains and to deal with what
is a big security problem now obviously
picking up from the the issues that the
Obama administration had with the the
Taliban and again what do you what do
you think that as they they reassess
policy in Afghanistan what do you
think's ahead well I think it's it's
very important that we engage the the
Afghans and indeed the Pakistanis at the
senior level HR McMaster of course a
veteran of tours in Afghanistan he and I
were there together he understands the
issues and he knows what the stakes are
clearly we've got to work with the
Afghans to first stabilize the situation
against a a Taliban onslaught and then
move ahead with a political process that
is going to have to include Pakistan Hey
look I bill I was ambassador there for
three years and it's it's very
frustrating
like you you have to understand the
Pakistani perspective as well we walked
out of them we walked out on them in the
early 90s after the Soviet defeat in
Afghanistan slapping sanctions on them
and heading home
Pakistan is ever gonna forget that what
we have to do now is provide some
assurances that this time we're not
going home
this time we're going to stay with
whatever force composition makes sense
because we have vital interests at stake
here
as long as the Pakistanis see us as
and out the door again they're not gonna
turn against the the Taliban that would
leave them what's a mortal enemy they
have enough of those already
our guest is Ryan Crocker former
ambassador to six us to six countries
including Iraq Afghanistan and Syria we
welcome your phone calls and comments -
OH - seven four eight eight thousand one
for Republicans - OH - seven four eight
eight thousand for Democrats
independents and others that's - OH -
seven four eight eight thousand and two
executive professor at Texas A&M
University what what does a what does an
executive professor mean Ron Crocker it
means that I don't have a PhD another
term that's often used is a professor of
practice but it amounts to the same
thing people who are in a faculty not
because of their academic achievement
God knows I don't have many of those to
register but because of their experience
in the real world we're focusing our
conversation on the recent military
actions in Syria and Afghanistan but
frauding it broadening out here a bit
ambassador based on your experience in
the area look at the the recent election
the weekend election in Turkey and a
headline this morning from the
Washington Post writing that Trump
phones air Dewan on vote congratulating
the Turkish president calling that
calling a president to receive air Dewan
on Monday after referendum greatly
expanding his powers despite more
circumspect State Department response to
Sunday's vote which international
election observers declared unfair
according to accounts by both Trump and
air Dewan the two also discussed the US
missile strike on a Syrian Air Base what
do you think the the the ramifications
of this vote in Turkey might be -
especially when our efforts in Syria I
think it is very important to be deeply
engaged with the Turks what they do or
don't do in the weeks ahead could
dramatically affect the outcome of the
campaign against Islamic state so I
certainly understand what
President Trump was trying to do
obviously the Turks are doing things we
may not like well of course we're doing
stuff they may not like but it's
critically important that we maintain a
dialogue with them as as we move ahead
with a campaign against the Islamic
state stronghold in Raqqa we have calls
for our guest ambassador Ryan Crocker
let's hear from James in South Bend
Indiana on our Democrats line
hi mr. Crocker I just wanted to get your
thoughts on trillions and trillions of
dollars in US tax dollars u.s. military
in a hundred and fifty countries and the
biblical passage we're just coming off
very easter holidays James for one and
the old and the Bible states the cause
and source of all war is greed and
corruption wanted to get your thoughts
on that Christian matter well certainly
corruption is a problem throughout that
region it's a problem in Afghanistan in
in Pakistan corruption kind of laid the
foundations or actually undermined the
foundations of a number of states in the
area that have now virtually collapsed
so these are important issues and by the
way general McMaster when he was in
Afghanistan led an interagency task
force to get at this cancer of
corruption so it's hugely important I
think a broader issue is what role does
the US see for itself in the
international community you know for
basically six decades after World War
two the United States was a leader in
the international community we created
much of the architecture of the post-war
world in the u.s. San Francisco created
the United Nations Bretton Woods New
Hampshire the new international
financial order and and I do think for
for our interests and the interests of
the Internet
community we've got to continue to to
show that leadership and one way to do
it again is having your your top cabinet
level and above officials out in these
key regions resubmitting our traditional
ties getting assessments and then moving
forward to zero to seven four eight
eight thousand one the number to call
for Republicans to oh two seven four
eight eight thousand for Democrats and
all others two oh two seven four eight
eight thousand to send us a tweet at
c-span WJ former ambassador Ryan Crocker
Iraq part one of your one of your
postings from 2007 through 2009 and a
headline here in the Washington Post
Iraqi Prime Minister my country needs
more help from the US huh Doral Abadi
wrote wrote this last month I should say
that two weeks I visit two weeks ago he
wrote I visited Iraqi troops in western
Mosul as they prepared to liberate the
last terrorists controlled neighborhoods
in the city by any standards they are
heroes I did not ask their religious
regional or ethnic origins I saw them
for what they were Iraqis standing
together against the cruelest killers on
earth
he writes that having spilled our blood
together with the United States to win
this war we want to work together to win
the peace and then he visited writes
about visiting president Trump at his
invitation at the conference recently in
Washington on the global coalition to
counter ISIL President Trump and I
discussed how to build on the strategic
framework our countries signed in 2008
that strategic framework ambassador
Crocker what did that define that that
was negotiated during my my time in
Baghdad it's a it's a very broad
agreement that outlines basis for
cooperation obviously in the security
field but also on economic issues and so
forth so it it is a very good touchstone
and I don't say that just because I'm
the one who signed it it is a way of
shaping our relationship
with an iraq that is a strategic partner
iraq has never been that in modern times
and whether it was prior to the advent
of saddam or subsequent so this is an
opportunity now to sit down with the
iraqis it needs to be it again at a
cabinet level go through the agreement
set our agenda set our priorities and
and move forward as strategic partners
here is osprey florida we hear from Paul
on our Democrats line for Ryan Crocker
go ahead Paul ambassador Crocker I
wanted to ask you whether you think the
only viable government in Afghanistan
that will work is one with a weak
central government and local politicians
who are actually warlords have probably
have their own armies who can take care
of their own areas and fight the Taliban
Oh Afghanistan has has always been
decentralized you know many Afghan
governments would have wished it
otherwise but you know that is simply
the way it is so whoever rules in Kabul
is going to have to deal with a
periphery that may not be on the same
page and you know that's not for us to
decide I would just simply express the
hope that as and if we start making
headway against the Taliban militarily
that we are looking at shoring up
political relations not so much between
us and the Afghans but among the Afghans
themselves so if it's if
decentralization is going to continue
that might work but it will only work if
provincial figures are basically in sync
with the Kabul government if they're
going their own way with their own
armies nothing good as it likes it
happen another view on Turkey and back
to the the issue of the Turkish
elections the referendum this weekend
Steve tweets a u.s. president
congratulating a Turkish loud
on eliminating atatürk stream of Western
democracy I'd expect that from Trump but
ambassador Crocker you say at this point
it's important for the administration to
stay engaged in Turkey look absolutely
clearly political events have moved in
Turkey in a way we may not like but we
we cannot forget that they were a
founding member of NATO and are still a
key NATO ally in that context so look
here's here's how I see it
in the broader Middle East Turkey as
part of Europe not the Middle East but
they used to own most of the Middle East
so it's important we we don't have the
luxury of a choice between democracy and
autocracy the choice we have is between
the forces of order and the forces of
disorder it is very important that
Turkey
stand with us and we with them as a key
force of order in a very troubled region
let's go again we we may not like the
way the politics are playing out in
Turkey but we have some pretty important
strategic interests at stake let's get
one more call for a Ryan Crocker lowest
Lewistown Montana Robert on the
independent line good morning good
morning I was just wondering what the
Ambassador felt like and the situation
that the United States has been
described lately as the only remaining
superpower one and stay Rome was the
superpower and they had Fox Romana and
England and Great Britain was super
power in this 1800s and they had the
white man's burden how do we avoid
ending up trying to police the entire
world take care of the entire world and
suddenly discover we've spent all our
time and energy taking care of the
entire world and we miss things at home
it seems to me we sort of almost be seem
to be heading that way thank you
look III think we can do both things we
are a great power but the world needs
our leadership we are not creating a new
Roman Empire by any means we are
consulting with allies we are getting
their perspectives and we are figuring
out how we can safeguard our own
interests and indeed the interest of the
international community look today's the
18th of April it was 34 years ago today
that the American embassy in Beirut was
blown up I am a survivor of that attack
so you know we want to keep the fight if
there have to be fights away from our
borders right now that means political
engagement and again this is what the
Secretary of Defense the vice president
and the National Security Advisor are
doing because what happens in that
region unfortunately doesn't stay in
that region that's what we learned on
9/11 so we've got to be engaged we've
got to know who stands where we got to
know who needs our assistance we got to
know what their concerns are you know
bear in mind that there were there was a
two decade pause between World Wars 1
and 2 the United States did not
participate in the post-world War 1
political life of Europe and we got
World War 2 it's been over 70 years now
without a major ground war in Europe US
leadership counts in the world it counts
for our security it counts for
international security ambassador
Crocker thanks for pointing out the that
anniversary
he served in as ambassador to Beirut
from 1992-93 one of six foreign
countries that Ryan Crocker has served
the United States as ambassador we
welcome your expertise this morning but
we value your health even more and let
you go rest your voice Ryan Crocker but
really appreciate you joining us this
morning hope you'll be back here on
Washington
Journal thanks Bill and I would point
out College Station Texas is the allergy
capital of the world
I don't know Washington DC may may vie
for that - thanks for being with us
thank you a live picture from the
Washington Institute for Near East
policy which this afternoon is hosting a
conversation on the results of turkeys
referendum this past Sunday Turkish
voters approved changes to their
Constitution that'll change the country
system of government - from
parliamentary to presidential this is
live coverage should get it away in just
a moment
[Music]
good afternoon good afternoon welcome to
the Washington Institute I'm Rob sotloff
the executive director and I'm delighted
to welcome all of you to this very
special event
before I begin if I can please ask
everyone to take your iphones or
samsung's and whatever and turn them on
on silent because we are broadcasting
live on c-span one so please watch your
language speak in clear tones some
people around the world can hear us
today you are free to to tweet as much
as you like because we are eager to get
the message of today's discussion out
far and wide it is not often that one
can time the publication of a new book
so propitiously to an international
event or perhaps I should say it's not
often that one can arrange an
international referendum in a faraway
country to be timed perfectly with the
publication of a new book but as it
turns out we have today this confluence
of events we have the referendum in
Turkey that although it the results and
the process were provocative and
remained controversial and subject to
great debate and I'm sure we're going to
hear more about that the result seems to
be to elevate the existing president of
Turkey into an even higher more elevated
position one that one might be able to
call the new Sultan surprisingly enough
that is the title of this new book by
the director of the Washington
Institute's Turkish research program so
near chop tie the new Sultan air Diwan
and the crisis of modern Turkey so right
away we know that Turkey is a country in
crisis as the title and subtitle of
centers outstanding new work suggests
and the subject of today's discussion is
what type of crisis how lasting a crisis
a crisis at home a crisis abroad a
crisis getting worse or a crisis getting
better now for all the provocation and
controversy that there may even be some
clarity about the direction of Turkish
leadership and to talk about these
questions first I'm going to be quite
delighted to welcome to the podium the
author of the new Sultan my colleague
the buyer family fellow here at the
Institute
Turner Chubb time and then we have an
outstanding array of Turkish expertise
here on the panel and as I look around
the audience a remarkable array of
Turkish expertise within these four
walls but after I turn to so Nair I'm
delighted to welcome to the podium
Gunilla tole who is the founding
director of the Middle East Centre for
Turkey of the Middle East Institute's
Center for Turkish studies and an
adjunct professor at George Washington
University's Institute for Middle East
Studies here in Washington and then
we'll turn to Amber and Zaman who is a
public policy fellow at the Woodrow
Wilson Center's Middle East program the
veteran journalists writing for
al-monitor 15 years the Turkish
correspondent for The Economist really
delighted to have this panel which
brings such in-depth knowledge of the
current political situation and the
likely direction of politics of Turkey
and special interests to this audience
of course the direction of the u.s.
Turkish relationship in this new era
we've already seen the the first sign of
the direction of the u.s. Turkish
relationship of course with president
Trump's outreach to the newly Rhian ter
Diwan
just yesterday I'm now going to call the
podium my colleague Sona Sona has been
with the Institute now for many years
he's the author of
of several books on Turkish domestic and
foreign policy and I think one of
Senators greatest claims to fame is that
there is a direction that there's a
generation of American foreign service
officers who have gone on to to serve
America abroad in Turkey who have passed
through centers tender mercies as an
instructor of American diplomats abroad
and I think that we are all better
served for that that that America's
representatives in Turkey have had the
benefit of so neurs insight and wisdom
and that's really one of the things we
try to do here at the Institute is not
just opine in books op-eds and
television but to do what we can to
improve the quality of American foreign
policy by such things as as teaching
American diplomats and so I'm really
delighted to have so near so near the
podium is yours thank you rob and I'm so
pleased to see so many of my friends and
colleagues from around town it's a great
day for me I really appreciate that girl
here I also wanted to thank I'm Marian
and Gunnar for joining me at this panel
there are two of the top notch experts
in town on Turkish politics if you
haven't seen it yet you know had an
excellent op-ed in The New York Times
this morning on Turkey after referendum
I loved reading and I'm Erin is a
frequent commentator on various issues
and I'm a I've been a follower for work
for nearly two decades so I'm very
pleased that both are with me at this
panel today I also wanted to start of
course by a thanking president Rajab
typer Don he is for well timing the
referendum to overlap with the launch of
my book and I couldn't have done it with
Adam this is literally and figuratively
this is obviously a critical time in
Turkish history I just want to tell you
but first of my book the new Sultan I
decided to write this book last year in
June and the whole original idea was
that I would write it over a year it
would be edited sometime this spring and
publish in the next summer then the cool
happens
as I was writing the book my editors
reached out to me and they asked me to
pull up the deadline I agreed so I wrote
it between coming back from the beach in
August and Christmas in December about
four months and then it was edited and
copy edited and proof read and designed
and typeset and printed in the last
three months and there you go in my
hands the new Sultan I'm very proud of
the book of course but I really want to
thank once again a number of people who
to whom I of gratitude for getting this
work together of course first of all my
boss Rob setliffe because he is my boss
and I'm doing salary review with him
right now
thank you rob and the Institute and my
colleagues this is a great place to work
I would say it's one of the best places
to work and probably the best
intellectual incubator
I've enjoyed tremendously my tenure here
in the last 15 years I'm feel lucky to
be surrounded by so many smart people
and my colleagues as well as our
research assistants I have been blessed
in the last decade and a half by a very
impressive group of interns and research
assistants some of them are in this room
I see mara Gemma's here you guys are
both in the book thank you but of course
the biggest thanks goes to Oya sitting
up in the front would you get up for a
second sorry to embarrass you yeah thank
you it was with me at every stage in the
writing of this book I hope that I did
not drive her crazy thanks for bearing
with me we went through every sentence
literally together of instances where I
would tell her a sentence and she would
finish it I would say have you looked at
that typo and she would say yes I fixed
it so thank you I could not have this
without you I should also mention that I
have dedicated this book to the loving
memory of my mother I was born into a
working-class family in eastern Turkey
and I went to Yale for my PhD and my
parents who have raised me and my
siblings deserve indefinite gratitude
and so this goes to my mom's memory but
I want to turn to my book now why I
wrote it and what it's really about and
then I'll go to my colleagues and we'll
have it hopefully a good discussion on
that the fellow Turkish politics is a
student for nearly two decades I've
written on it in the last 15 years I've
been at the Institute analyzing and
writing on
Turkey so for those of you follow my
work you'll find traces of our
discussions in this book and in many
ways the new Sultan
follows my previous book as Rob is
mentioned the rise of Turkey this in
this book I looked at Turkey's economic
growth under President air Doan
currently Prime Minister previously and
his Justice and Development Party and I
argued that after having turkey had
witnessed tremendous economic growth in
the last decade that after having been
transformed economically are the ones
task was not to to transform Turkey
politically to this end I said and I
believe this that I think everyone wants
to make turkey a great power and I said
the path to that goes through becoming
an advanced economy and that everyone
has made Turkey a country which makes
and sells cars but to become an advanced
economy Turkey has to become a hub for
Google and the path to that goes through
becoming an open society and the liberal
democracy so I argued in my book the
rise of Turkey that the homework was
therefore to get to that advanced
society economy and open society to
build it a new liberal democratic order
one that would provide for freedoms for
the two halves of Turkey that which I'm
gonna discuss in a minute that is
freedom of religion for the religious
half and freedom from religion for the
secular half roughly defined and that
this new constitution would have to
provide for broad liberties for all
citizens including the Kurds
I concluded that relieved of its
perennial secular religious tensions and
the burden of the Kurdish problem inside
and outside of the country Turkey would
then soar become an it avoid the trap of
a middle-income economy and become a
great power I don't think they're done
with my book so I wrote this one now the
crisis of Turkey so let me now tell you
what the crisis is and where I think it
is heading the book is really a story of
Iran's power consolidation in Turkey
since 2003 when he became prime minister
I've tracked various steps of it happy
to look at it in the Q&A and I argue in
the conclusion that air Doan has become
as unassailable as was Ataturk once
meaning he is the most powerful Turk
but the problem is half of Turkey loves
him and the other half of Turkey loads
him and that is the crisis in which
turkey has found itself as a result of
air diwan's political trajectory
what is more I argue in my book that
order one now wants to shape turkey in
his own image in a way once up in a time
Ataturk did so I suggest that he's
following what I call in quotes that is
Ataturk motto what is the Ataturk model
in the early 20th century Ataturk set up
Turkey as a modern state and then he
shaped it in his own image using state
power including education policy as a
secular Western European society and
elder one wants to use the Ataturk model
but of course I think he's taking a cue
from Ataturk the country's founder but
he wants to both emulate and replace
Ataturk of course he does not share
Ataturk values just methods that is
top-down social engineering and he wants
to use state power once again including
the educational policy to shape Turkey
in his own image very different than
Avatar Turkey a country that would
therefore become as inner Dawn's vision
to the core Islamic politically that is
religious and Middle Eastern and
conservative and that's a top-down kind
of Giacobbe and methods that I think
that everyone is borrowing from Ataturk
the Ataturk model but everyone is a
problem Ataturk was a military general
erawan has a Democratic mandate or I
should say he had one until this Sunday
there is widespread consensus that
election process was not fair and there
is emerging consensus that there were
irregularities during the day of the
voting we don't know the scale of the
irregularities but that's the boy the
problem is because erdowan has suggested
to move forward he has declared himself
executive style president he said that's
over we're not going back to the
election so he has at best a mandate in
question for half of the country that
doesn't support him and that only
accessor Bates Turkey's deep societal
polarization in my view to vote does not
alleviate it it actually accessor baits
the divide and turkeys split in the
middle therefore between Pro and anti
arrow on Kemps I also argue in the book
that it's unlikely that other one will
be able to impose
vision that I highlighted on the entire
Turkish society Turkey said as you know
there many experts on Turkey in this
room I see some of my friends and former
students from the State Department we've
discussed this many times this is a very
complicated country of a melange of
political ethnic religious and social
groups and the other ones difficult that
it's going to impose his vision on the
entire country entire society we saw
this in Sunday's referendum a near
majority if not a majority of Turks
voted against it
and what's more importantly I think we
have a map of Turkey if we can put it on
there for a second there you go you can
see on the map from Anatolian agency I
will well make a number of Turkish
provinces along the coast and Northwest
representing an overwhelming percentage
of turkeys GDP voted against him he lost
Istanbul Ankara and Izmir all three
large cities Istanbul is its home city
he lost that Istanbul is where he
started this political career which I
track in my book in 1994 when he became
its mayor that was his stage that's what
he provided good governance cleaned up
the city it is why the Turks decided to
give him the benefit of doubt and make
him prime minister later on and helped
his AKP rise to power so he's lost that
he's lost obviously supportive and some
of the key cities of the country but
more importantly as well as losing in
the Kurdish areas he's lost Istanbul
including his own neighborhood in
Istanbul so those are very significant
developments to me it suggests that it's
gonna be impossible for him to impose
his vision on the entire society going
forward I argue in my book that Turkey
is simply too large demographically too
big economically and too complicated
politically for one person to control it
in its entirety
despite Irwin's efforts to create a
crony class of capitalists for instance
Tasya to turkey's fortune 500 which
controls a large part of turkey's
economic wealth is still wedded to
liberal democratic secular and european
value so it's gonna be really hard for
him to move forward
let me now look at trajectories which
are highlighted in my book going forward
I see three trajectories from here
moving forward and I'm gonna conclude it
a little bit looking at po
referendum foreign policy environment
which I think deserves some discussion
as well
the first trajectory is the current
state of affairs state of crisis deeply
polarized society in which half of the
country that is the prior Don wing of
Turkey conservative Islamist nationalist
three groups who believe that Turkey is
heaven and the other half a loose
coalition of opposition figures
socialists leftist Social Democrats
Kurds alavés who are liberal Muslims who
believe that turkeys hell and this is
the best case of in my view
unfortunately going forward this
permanent state of crisis that turkeys
stuck under so long as turkey is
genuinely democratic everyone cannot
continue to govern the way that he wants
and there's a chance that he might
become even more autocratic going
forward there's a chance that he might
even end democracy in Turkey going
forward
that is the second trajectory the third
is an extension of the second societal
polarization coupled with attacks from
the right by far-right by Isis from the
far left by PKK together with nefarious
neighbors that surround Turkey all of
whom want air doens fall from Russia to
Assad regime to Iran could I argue in my
book could even catapulter key into
unfortunate and unwanted civil conflict
that's a scenario I will have to be able
to hash hash out for you in the Q&A of
course but I really want to turn now and
look at everyone's foreign policy
challenges because we haven't discussed
that yet and I spent a lot of time in
the book about how Russia of course is
the nemesis that keeps coming despite
the fact that the Russians are friendly
towards their dough on their making up
they're also deploying troops and
setting up a base in offering a frame is
an enclave controlled by YPG which is
allied with the PKK which are Doan is
fighting US policy also works with YPG
but only where there is Isis Russia
isn't a friend where there is no Isis
our FreeNAS surrounded by Assad regime
Turkey back rebels and Turkey guess who
the Russia is there to hurt it's
obviously not the Assad regime it's
Turkey and its allies so going forward I
think Russia is going to be our dorrance
nemesis as well as as well as most
feared
but does this mean our dawn is coming to
the bosom of the Western world he's not
and we kind of saw this in the route to
the election both the Western European
Union became a punching bag in the
run-up to the referendum and I think
this is going to continue that was a lot
to do with everyone's next step yes he
has become executive style president but
he also wants to obviously their
elections coming up he has to win those
elections that's for the Parliament his
party something interesting happened in
the last election if we can demap is
still there so some of the voters of the
nationalist Action Party which is a
smaller faction in the Turkish
Parliament that polls just about 10
percent voted for erawan in the
referendum and some of them voted
against him in the referendum this is an
important party it's one of the four
parties in the parliament it's splitting
the split happy is happening where
voters in central and northeastern
Anatolia with MHP are flipping for Iran
and MHP voters in the coastal provinces
and large cities are flipping against
their dough on that is music to
everyone's ears because it means that he
can solidify AKP s popularity with
voters flocking to its party from MHP
this is the ultra-nationalist party it
also suggests that MHP support to Iran
not only strengthens AKP but in case of
new elections snap or on time
parliamentary elections MHP will fail
turkey's high 10% electoral threshold
when that happens a KP has super
majority in the parliament with as
little as 45 perhaps even under that
kind of percentage of vote I think
that's everyone's goal going forward so
that means ultra-nationalist on foreign
policy issues on the European Union I
anticipate major problems in ties with
Europe
he's just suggested he might want to
bring back capital punishment that would
end up with Turkey being kicked out of
Council of Europe if Turk is kicked out
of Council of Europe Turkish courts will
not be recognizing European Court of
Human Rights as the highest court of the
country Turkish citizens will not have
access to that I think that changes the
political dynamics in the country
because he controls the courts I also
anticipate a hard Nationalist foreign
policy line towards us cooperation with
YPG because that is in line what is
hardline policy on the Kurds in general
to flirt to make sure that MHP voters
that have flipped for him in the
referendum become permanent AKP voters I
think that's his game going forward I
have provided you with so much doom and
gloom I want to bring some good news
before I answer there's a fourth
trajectory for Turkey I've given you
three in my book I don't want to tell
you all about because I want you to buy
it
then the fourth trajectory excludes
everyone this is it's because of him but
despite him scenario so he's made turkey
wealthy thanks to him this is a
middle-class society that's what he
deserves credit turkey has grown it has
better infrastructure its citizens live
better off than they did before the fact
that from my previous book that I liked
most rise of Turkey is that when
everyone came to power infant mortality
rate in Turkey was comparable to pre-war
Syria and now it is comparable to Spain
Turks used to live like Syrians now they
live like this Spanish that's why
they're voting for a law that's
primarily it but I also argue that this
growth has built a middle-class space
and now they're making some very
middle-class demands and it is the
wealthier provinces along the the
Mediterranean and the Aegean and the
Marmora see that I voted against him in
the referendum so that's a good sign
going forward but I don't want to get
carried away with the case for a liberal
Turkey because number one the opposition
the that's against their own of course
is an extremely divided one it's as
large as the prior to one camp but very
divided it includes Turkish and Kurdish
nationalists seculars and conservatives
center right and center left
sometimes the gap between them is the
wider is wider than the gap between them
and air donor that's a challenge but
there's a bigger challenge to go back to
the leadership issue the opposition
lacks a charismatic leader conservative
Islamists Turks have their own Ataturk
in quotes that is their dough on but the
real Ataturk of course is dead and that
is the challenge for the other half of
Turkey that wants to oppose Iran and I
think until that at the day that such a
man or women emerges who can make a case
for a liberal turkey liberal Turkey that
would have a constitution that would
provide freedom of religion and freedom
from religion simultaneous
that would provide broad liberties for
all individual liberties including
cultural liberties for all as including
the Kurds until that moment comes I
remain deeply worried about Turkey's
future but I do think that while liberal
Turkey remains a distant dream it is
plausible given the economic
transformation that turkey has gone
under aired all sorts
perhaps thanks to him that I'm gonna
write my next book as well so watch this
space and thank you everybody for coming
I appreciate everyone first of course
son our congratulations I think he's one
of the most productive turkey experts in
town he makes us look lazy and my boss
loves you aside from that I really
enjoyed reading your book but of course
when I picked up the book the first
thing came to my mind was which Sultan
so I think at this point after Sunday's
referendum many of us can live with
Suleiman the Magnificent who was a
reformer but what about Sultan
Abdulhamid
who was a truly authoritarian ruler I
think the book does a great job of
opening a window into
Adhan psyche and through telling his
personal narrative and this is a
narrative of victimhood which resonates
very well among his constituency and
actually beyond it's showing us the
interplay the interaction between the
founding ideology humanism and the
reactions to it so that's why I
particularly enjoyed reading the
chapters on Kurdish nationalism and
Islamism both reactions to to the
Kemalists ideology
but I think Turkey right now lives in a
post Kemalists
and post Islamist era and one would
expect this year r2 to embrace liberal
values because both Kem Ellison and
Islamism they're both radical
authoritarian ideologies so this post
Kemalist and post Islamist era is not
really embracing liberalism liberal
values and the opposite is actually
happening as well now as when I
mentioned in the book there is now a
growing middle class in Turkey and they
are demanding middle-class values so
this is striking because at a time when
there is a growing middle class in
Turkey they are not really demanding
middle-class values instead there is a
growing motor arianism and i think there
is it's because there is something
inherently authoritarian in Turkish
political culture and some might blame
me for being an essentialist but but I
believe that that is really that is that
lies at the heart of the issue here and
I think the original sin of turkeys
political culture is the loss of the
status ideology I mean the state
occupies a very unique place in the
turkey psyche development rebuilding the
society everything has been done through
state and even the wool was created by
the state itself and that's why we have
a middle class that's why we have a
business class that's not really
standing up against our dong
authoritarian policies in the 21st
century instead many are aligning with
with with the government so that loss of
bourgeoisie I think starting from from
the late 19th century and rebuilding of
the bourgeoisie by the state itself
I think that was problematic and and and
and again I think that explains the
state of Turkish democracy at the moment
and and the people who are supporting
our don because I think on Sunday going
back to the Islamism versus humanism or
secularism debate I think the people who
voted on Sunday in favor of the
referendum the 50% they were not voting
for for Islamism and those who were
opposed to it they were not obviously
entirely Kemalists either so there's
something else going on here and and the
50% that voted YES on Sunday they just
do not mind authoritarianism and of
course this is this is a very dark
picture so where do we go from here and
I'm a bit optimistic about Sunday's
results because I think the slim the
razor thin majority that he captured on
Sunday gives me hope and at the end
electoral politics will play a role but
I think more than that of course we
don't know what his ardent strategy will
be moving forward but I believe despite
his victory he has lost ground
he has lost ground within his own
constituency he lost all major cities
including Istanbul which is a very
important place he launched his
political career in Istanbul and he
hasn't lost since mid-1990s so the fact
that he lost Istanbul is very telling
and and some of his base especially the
educated urban
bass I don't think they are 100% happy
with his authoritarian tendencies and
also he in the run-up to the referendum
he he played to the Nationalists his
main strategy was galvanizing the
nationalist vote so he employed this
very ultra nationalistic rhetoric and
yet I think that strategy didn't pay off
he could not be able to mobilize the
national space as much as he wanted to
and instead he increased his votes in in
the Kurdish region compared to two
November elections which is surprising
he increased of course it's right now
it's very fluid it's very difficult to
be sure about the numbers but what we're
hearing from especially from local
journalists is that hundreds of
thousands of people the ruling party the
AKP increase its vote by around 400,000
which is almost 1% and and he I think I
Don took a note of that and in his
victory speech sorry the one before that
on the day of the referendum he said
that we increased our votes in in in the
Kurdish region so if he really wants to
return the favor
that I think that is good news so
instead of aligning with the
Nationalists this time he might have to
recalibrate recalibrate his strategy and
maybe work with the Kurds and that could
mean and I know my friend and my
colleague here on Baron disagrees with
me but he might go back to the
negotiations resumed the peace talks
with the curves of course if he choose
to play to the instead of aligning with
the Nationalists working with with the
Kurds so that is good news that would be
good news not only domestically also a
Turkish economy has been hit hard by by
by a terrorist attacks so that would be
good news for